لذلك بدأ الرئيس الإيراني
تحقيقًا في التسجيل
الصوتي المسرب لوزير الخارجية جواد
ظريف ،
لكن هناك بالفعل عواقب مع
المبعوث الخاص لتغير المناخ ، جون
كيري ، الذي نفى بشكل قاطع
اتهامات الجمهوريين
بأنه شارك العمليات العسكرية الإسرائيلية السرية
مع وزير خارجية إيران
المذكور على ما يبدو في ذلك
صوت مسرب يقول وزير الخارجية الأمريكي
أنطوني بلينكين إنه
هراء مطلق ، ما رأيك في كل
هذا
جيدًا أعتقد أن وزير خارجية إيران
أه لديه أه جو هو أن لديها الكثير من
الخصوم في الداخل بين زملائه الأكثر
تشددًا في إيران
الحكومة التي سعت إلى
تدميره حقًا وأتوقع
أنه ربما لا يمتلك
هذا القدر من المستقبل أه بعد
مدته
أه أه تنتهي كوزير للخارجية هذا
الصيف
لا أعتقد أن جون كيري
سيتأثر حقًا بهذه
ادعاءات من زادي عن هذه
الاكتشافات
وفي نهاية اليوم لا أعتقد أن هذا
التسريب حقيقي  لي
يغير ديناميكية المفاوضات النووية الإيرانية الأمريكية
إما
أم أن الولايات المتحدة أه لا تزال
ملتزمة بالاتفاق من أجل إحياء
الاتفاق النووي لأسباب أمنية
وما زالت إيران بحاجة إلى
إحياء الاتفاق النووي
لأسباب اقتصادية كل شيء على
ما يرام  وأريد الوصول إلى الصفقة
لأن
[الموسيقى] الإيرانية
كانت هناك قوارب هجومية ضايقت
سفن حربية لنا في الخليج الفارسي يوم الاثنين
وكل هذا يجري بينما
تُبذل الجهود للتفاوض بشأن إحياء
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني لعام 2015 مع الصين البريطانية
اتفقت فرنسا وألمانيا وروسيا يوم
الثلاثاء على
محاولة تسريع الجهود لإعادة
الولايات المتحدة وإيران
إلى الامتثال لتلك الصفقة ،
حيث تعتقد أن كل هذا
سيتكرر مرة أخرى.
تدرك الحكومة الإيرانية في الأسابيع والأشهر القادمة أن إدارة بايدن
ملتزمة بمحاولة
إحياء هذه الصفقة ، لذا فهم
سيحاولون الحصول على أكبر قدر من
العقوبات.  إليف قدر الإمكان وأنت
لديك أيضًا أه تعرف عناصر أخرى
داخل
النظام الإيراني وسيواصل الحرس الثوري
مضايقتنا لسفننا في الخليج الفارسي
سيستمرون في
أه معارضة مصالحنا وحلفائنا في
الشرق الأوسط  سواء
كنت تعرف هجمات أه ضد إسرائيل أو
أو شركائنا في الخليج الفارسي
ولكن في نهاية اليوم كل الـ
p5 زائد واحد الولايات المتحدة فرنسا
ألمانيا
أه بريطانيا
روسيا والصين كما ذكرت كل
هذه البلدان  ملتزمة
بإحياء
الصفقة وإيران لا يمكنها حقًا عكس اتجاه
تدهورها الاقتصادي إذا لم يتم
تخفيف العقوبات عليها ، لذا
فإن توقعي هو أننا سنرى عودة
كاملة أو جزئية
للاتفاق النووي في وقت ما في عام